[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui
l'économiste yves perez pour son livre
les vertus du protectionnisme d'après
lui si la france a réussi à conserver si
longtemps ses parts de marché dans la
compétition économique mondiale pendant
un siècle de la fin du second empire à
la crise du pétrole
c'est grâce au protectionnisme et si
elles déclinent depuis ce n'est pas
parce que le l'économie s'est
mondialisée que tout a changé c'est
parce qu'elle a renoncé au
protectionnisme il va nous expliquer ça
en détail mais d'abord on commence par
une image symbolisant notre époque voici
celle que vous avez choisi perez
alors pourquoi ce drone de la police
aurait coûté c'est un policier m'a les
manipule un drone qui surveille une rue
passante alors ça m'a ça m'a évoqué
notre île achetée par une quelques temps
où on voyait une amie chinoise qui
voulaient traverser la rue était un feu
rouge a voulu traverser l'épidémie
battait son plein et le ya un drone qui
est dessus d'elle qui lui parle et qui
lui dit de rentrer chez elle met un
masque parce qu'elle n'a pas le droit de
se balader dans la rue sans masque et je
me rappelle sam a ainsi rappelé le
souvenir de cette petite mamie qui était
complètement complètement ahuri de voir
ce drone qui lui parlait quoi alors pour
moi ça signifie deux choses ça signifie
que la mondialisation on nous avait dit
que ça allait être triomphe des
individus et puis le la disparition ou
la fin des frontières ou la disparition
des frontières et là en fait on
s'aperçoit que ben l'individu on le met
sous surveillance pour des raisons sur
lesquelles je reviendrai pas qu'ils
peuvent être tout à fait positive
enfin on le met sous surveillance et les
frontières
quand on nous avait annoncé un petit peu
la fin elles reviennent alors c'est des
frontières sanitaire cd frontier
economics et des frontières politiques
peu importe mais on assiste au à ses
retours des frontières et donc cette
image mois elle symbolise un petit peu
ce voilà ce retour que la pandémie a
accéléré incontestablement et là elle a
donné des coups d'accélérateur
à ces évolutions là comme dans d'autres
dans d'autres domaines et bien
commençons
[Musique]
yves férès vous avez été professeur et
doyen de l'université catholique de
l'ouest à angers vous enseigner
aujourd'hui au l'école militaire de
saint cyr coëtquidan dans les vertus du
protectionnisme qui paraît aujourd'hui
chez l'artilleur vous dites que les
dirigeants français visaient autrefois
la sauvegarde d'une économie complexe
c'est à dire fondée sur l' équilibre
entre l'agriculture elle et l'industrie
entre l'industrie légère et l'industrie
lourde et entre ce qui était produit
chez nous et ce qu'ils étaient apportés
de l'étranger
alors pourquoi et c'était si important à
leurs yeux le maintien de cette économie
complexe alors l'économie complexe on en
parle en france appartient après 1870
alors si tu c'est un d'un concept qu'on
trouve chez friedrich list l'économiste
allemand qui était l'un des pères du
théorie protectionnistes et on va
beaucoup lire friedrich list après 1870
et on va essayer de mettre en place une
économie qui soit la plus équilibrée
possible
c'est là où nos dirigeants actuels
depuis presqu'un demi siècle au fond
disent il faut se spécialiser droitement
par rapport à quelques créneaux sur le
marché mondial on l'avait au contraire à
l'époque dans les élites françaises
l'idée qu'une économie satisfaisante une
économie positive
c'était une économie la plus équilibrée
possible on ne dépendrait pas trop d'un
secteur papa plus de l'industrie lourde
que des biens de consommation pas plus
de l'étranger que du marché national
il fallait maintenir les grands
équilibres et ça c'est une pensée qui va
perdurer
je dirais à peu prés jusqu'aux années 60
on va on va être dans cette optique et
c'est à partir des années 70 notamment
après l'arrivée de valéry giscard
d'estaing au pouvoir que on va choisir
la carte de l'intégration dans l'union
européenne et une spécialisation de plus
en plus marquée de plus en plus forte
mais pour les élites françaises de la
fin du 19e et pendant toute une partie
du 20e siècle est presque là le dernier
quart du vingtième siècle il fallait
avoir l'économie de la plus équilibrée
possible de
pas trop dépendre du monde extérieur
rester toujours dans une
les anglo saxons en valeur et check and
balance un petit peu il faut regarder un
certain nombre d' équilibre et ne pas
trop mettre tous ses oeufs dans le même
panier
ça c'est une des récurrentes je dirais
un peu qu'on retrouve aussi bien chez
des hommes de gauche que de droite eux
chez des conservateurs que chez des
socialistes et des radicaux socialistes
cc transverses je dirais aux élites
économiques et politiques françaises de
cette époque et c'est ce que les images
qui sont derrière moi ce ne sont pas
tirés de votre livre sont simplement des
images de la france
de 1870 ça à 1960 à peu près donc
cette période que vous étudié
minutieusement non une période pour
laquelle le protectionnisme dit vous ne
signifiait pas le leur repli
derrière ses frontières à l'époque la
france la quatrième puissance
commerciale du monde et la deuxième
puissance financière
oui tout à fait là la france donc
d'après 1870 se reconstruit avec bien
sûr l'idée de d'équilibré autant que
faire se peut la puissance allemande
c'est un petit peu l'idée qui a dans la
tête des dirigeants français de l'époque
et la france va s'ouvrir
alors on protège l'agriculture française
parce qu'elle était menacée par ce qu'on
a appelé la mondialisation du commerce
des blés l'arrivée grâce au bateau à
vapeur et aux chemins de fer des blés du
nouveau monde c'était le canada les
etats-unis l'argentine est donc
l'agriculture française qui était une
agriculture très importante elle se
trouve littéralement prise en étau par
ces blés durs donc c'est pour ça qu'on
remet le protectionnisme il faut
défendre la population agricole
française qui représente à l'époque plus
de la moitié de la population active
alors certains se disent mais pourquoi
on a pas accélérer l'industrialisation
il ya un économiste britannique
s'appelle paul b rock qui est
aujourd'hui malheureusement décédé qui a
fait un travail remarquable ce sujet qui
a montré que si la france avait dû
absorber massivement une population
agricole quittant la terre
il aurait fallu qu'elles connaissent un
taux de croissance de l'ordre de 8 %
l'an or à l'époque ce n'était pas
possible
même les états unis ne croyez pas à 8%
il en était même très loin ce n'est pas
possible
le seul pays qui va croître avant 14 à 8
% lancé la russie tsariste et la russie
nicolas ii qui va connaître un boom
industriel incroyable mais c'est très
particulier et ça va être pendant une 12
ans à peu près donc la france va choisir
le protectionnistes pour protéger sur
l'agriculture et elle va commencer
alors elle va aussi sauvegarder en
sauvegardant le pouvoir d'achat des
agriculteurs ce qu'on appelle ce camp
les économies de l'époque capter
l'épargné paysanne les français à
épargner beaucoup c'était une nation de
bas de laine n'épargnant et le trait de
génie des financiers français d'avant
14c de drainer cette épargne les banques
françaises vont drainer cette épargne
ces capitaux pour les mettre au
développement au service du
développement de la russie tsariste
ils vont bien sûr servir au
développement si en france mais une
grande partie de ces capitaux vont
partir vers la russie tsariste qui est
en plein boom économique et alors il ya
une double pensée chez les dirigeants
français et une pensée économique faut
profiter de ce dynamisme économique de
la russie
et donc les les banques françaises vont
investir pour développer les chemins de
fer en russie tout ce qu'on a connu en
france sous le second empire
on va le refaire en russie à une plus
grande échelle et puis il ya une pensée
géostratégique
on est adversaire de l'allemagne
d'alsace lorraine elle est toujours en
entre la france et l'allemagne si je
puis dire quitte à l'époque annexée par
l'allemagne et on pense à la guerre
possible toujours possible et donc il
faut faire une alliance de revers avec
la russie pour si jamais l'allemagne
attaques qu'elle soit amenée à lutter
sur deux fronts c'était la pensée
profonde de l'état major mais aussi des
élites françaises de l'époque et on
verra que le plan va marcher
il a marché jusqu'en octobre certaines
octobre mois d'octobre 2010 7000 1917
pardon ou là la révolution éclate et
rien ne se passe plus comme prévu playa
ça sort du
des prévisions ça sort des scénarios qui
avait pu être faits à l'époque par la
france de l'époque
mais objectivement qui aurait pu
imaginer dans les années 1880 90 que des
bolchéviques qui était imparti
groupusculaire à l'époque prendrait un
jour le pouvoir en russie chose de assez
inimaginable pour les gens de l'époque
bon donc ça je le mets ça de côté c'est
une méthode est donc là la france va
s'ouvrir va la développer à participer
au développement de la russie
la place financière de paris va devenir
la deuxième du monde derrière celle de
londres
loin derrière celle de londres a failli
quand même la deuxième devant celle de
new york et de francfort et à vraiment
l'autre aspect c'est l' empire colonial
c'est que la france va ce aux coudes
sous la troisième république
cette époque se taillent et j'allais
dire un empire qui va être pas si
important que ça sur le plan économique
qui va servir de régulateur c'est à dire
quand la france recule sur les marchés
libres sur les marchés compétitifs
concurrentiel elle va pouvoir s'appuyer
sur le marché russe d'une part où elle a
des aspects ou là des commandites des
prix via un certain nombre de privilèges
politiques de deux d'entrés politique du
fait de l'alliance ce géo stratégique
avec la russie et sur les marchés
coloniaux ou la compétition évidemment
sera très réduite parce que la france
veille à ce que ces marchés soient
protégés et donc la france va avoir des
régulateurs qui vont lui permettre quand
elle recule face à ce que les économies
de l'époque l'abbé les grands rivaux
c'est à dire c'était l'allemagne
l'angleterre les etats-unis s'étaient
les trois grands rivaux à l'époque de la
france la france n'était que 4e assez
loin derrière les trois premiers mais
elle maintenait sa quatrième place
virulemment gérer bec et ongles grâce à
ce système à la fois de protectionnisme
en france et de marché protégé à
l'étranger à l'extérieur et
la france d'avant 14 connais une sorte
d'apogée à elle et elle et elle est la
deuxième puissance financière du monde
et la quatrième puissance commerciale
elle a un impact relativement important
alors que elle était peu favorisées
puisque son agriculture avait été
fortement attaquée par les agricultures
du nouveau monde et que elle s'ouvre est
chroniquement alors je l'expliqué dans
mon livre mais d'une pénurie de charbon
la france était pauvre en charbon
elle avait face à l'allemagne
l'angleterre les etats-unis qui étaient
des très grandes puissances charbonnier
à l'époque le charbon c'est le
combustible de la révolution
industrielle de l'industrie lourde des
industries de biens d'équipement la
france va innover beaucoup le corps des
mines en france les ingénieurs des mines
vont vraiment faire beaucoup
d'innovations contrairement à ce qu'on a
dit c'est une france qui est très
innovante et elliot beaucoup mais peut
pas rivaliser parce que bas le sol
français il prouve en charbon c'est
comme ça et d'ailleurs il ya deux autres
pays qui vont connaître une évolution
industrielle assez tardive aussi c'est
l'italie le japon l'italie le japon
pauvres en charbon
l'italie va s'industrialiser dans les
années 20 30 avec l'électricité ou
tourner entre cités et le japon bat lui
il va s'industrialiser il va se créer un
empire colonial d' en annexant la
mandchourie formose qu'on appelle taiwan
aujourd'hui et la corée marc taiwan la
corée émane de la man show était riche
en charbon donc eux ils vont parler paix
j'allais dire se résoudre la question
s'est fait de façon manu militari tout
notre façon de de faire de l'économie
évidemment que feront les japonais de
l'époque chantant et eau
voilà donc la france et dans cette n'est
pas une puissance dominante mais grâce à
ceux à cette stratégie d'économie
complexe de protectionnisme et de marché
protégé ll est quatrième c'est alors un
sas d'aucuns diront c'est du polidori
sme
j'avais pensé la peau leader peut-être
mais elle est là elle est pas lâcher et
elle est là elle et elle est dans le
peloton de tête quelque part elle
décolle pas du peloton de tête même si
les trois grandes puissances en question
sont devant
l'allemagne 214 est une puissance en
plein boum c'est la chine aujourd'hui on
veut comparer c'est la chine les etats
unis sont en train de sont déjà devenus
la première puissance industrielle du
monde avant 14 et l'angleterre reste la
première grande puissance financière et
commerciale du monde bien évidemment
donc ça reste une très grande puissance
avant 14 donc voila voila un petit peu
je dirai ce que je relate dans le livre
et qu'il n'est plus dit aujourd'hui on
s'est un petit peu à dire
protectionnisme donc régression donc
fermeture au monde pas du tout les
élites françaises de l'époque n'étaient
pas fermés au monde
au contraire on a on a une volonté de
d'être sur les marchés étrangers on a
une volonté de de commercer avec mais on
choisit des pôles
on a une stratégie de paul donc il ya un
pôle coloniale et il ya le pôle russe
qui vont être les deux grands pôles
d'avant 14 cantons va la russie va
passer du côté de la révolution du côté
du côté bolchévique save est un drame en
france revient pas sur la sphère faire
est connu cela est très connu les sépare
la ruine des épargnants français etc
c'est vrai ça va être un traumatisme
profond et la france cherchera toujours
à refaire cette stratégie des marchés
protégés avec des pays proches
politiquement militairement
stratégiquement sans jamais refaire un
coup pareil parce que remplace pas la
russie peut pas remplacer la russie
comme ça d'un coup de dé quelques
parrains évidemment évident donc mais
dans les années 20 30 la france va par
exemple se tourner vers la
tchécoslovaquie
vers la pologne elle va cherche la
roumanie elle va chercher avec ces pays
là à refaire un peu ce qu'elle avait
fait avec la russie d'avant guerre ça ne
durera pas très longtemps après le
retour de claire au pouvoir en 33
c'est l'allemagne qui va un peu
blackboulé les français dans ces pays là
sauf la pologne bien sûr
mais c'est l'allemagne qui va qui va m
on peut reprendre cette cet espace est
européen à son compte jeudi rien mais
prolongera après après la seconde guerre
mondiale elle prolongera sa stratégie d
état protège et s'adonnera à de gaulle
et pompidou et jacques chirac et
mitterrand d'ailleurs ça donnera l'irak
l'irak de saddam
la libye de kadhafi la france reproduira
sur une échelle plus d'abord le modeste
mais cette stratégie d'un pays qu'on
qu'on aide sur le plan militaire
stratégique qui nous donne du pétrole et
auquel on vend ou en des armes de la
technologie etc des produits de plus tôt
de haute technologie siri voilà ça c'est
quelque chose qui est resté jusqu'à
jusqu'à la chute de saddam et de kadhafi
qui restait un petit peu qu'ils étaient
dans le voilà dans les gènes de la
classe politique française est hélas
encore pas que d'un mort un jeune fils
de mon bouquin là dessus parce que on
voit que c'était plus une stratégie
nationale qu'une stratégie de droite ou
de gauche
les gaullistes et en joue un rôle
éminent général voit les choix rôle
éminent là dedans suivi par pompidou
mais mitterrand améliorée a poursuivi me
dire on a poussé très très loin
l'alliance avec sa d'armes avec la
l'irak de saddam et ça a duré jusqu'à la
seconde guerre du golfe et l'invasion
anglo américaine qui bien évidemment a
mis un terme à tout ça juste très vite
est ce qu'on peut dire que le marché
commun agricole d'abord puis la ceca
l'europe du charbon et de l'acier est ce
que ce c'est pas de continuer à faire
des marchés protégés au fond alors
l'europe telle qu'elle se construit à la
fin des années 50 au début des années 60
c'est presqu'une euros prélevés pour les
français parce que c'est une petite
europe c'est l'europe des six et la
france retrouve un
chez commun agricole protégée ya un
tarif extérieur commun agricole ce sera
le marché commun agricole est là la
france retrouve toute une série
d'avantagés concurrentiels qu'elle avait
perdu à la fin du 19e siècle avec ce que
j'ai présenté tout à l'heure avec la
mondialisation du commerce notamment du
commerce des blés là la france retrouve
un espace qui lui convient et où
l'agriculture française à pouvoir
s'épanouir se moderniser et se
développer
quant à l'industrie c'est pareil
l'industrie des six était protégé par le
tarif extérieur commun
alors bien évidemment cet équilibre qui
était très lié à un équilibre france
allemagne la france était la grande
puissance politique et militaire
l'allemagne était déjà une puissance
économie plus forte que la france dans
les années 60 mais il y avait check and
balance il y avait un équilibre entre la
france et l'allemagne 1 qui était à
l'époque à temps à partir des années
soixante quinze les choses vont évoluer
et plus le marché plus l'europe va
s'agrandir
ensuite après il y aura la réunification
allemande et là on va rentrer dans une
nouvelle période qui va être dominée par
un libre échange de plus en plus marquée
qui correspond à la volonté britanniques
et allemandes d'élargir le marché de
d'intégrer l'europe dans le marché
mondial
la france va s'y rallier elle va s'y
rallie en se disant qu'elle pourra
toujours tirer les épingles du jeu et ça
va être le discours des élites
françaises au début jusqu'à destin dire
à la france il faut que la france
rattrape l'allemagne ça c'est le disque
on va vendre dans les années 75 80
tehran le reprendre à un peu mois mais
le reprendre un petit peu et puis très
rapidement s'aperçoit que la france ne
rattrapera pas l'allemagne que
l'allemagne fait la course en tête et
qu'après avec la réunification
je dirait adieu veaux vaches cochons
l'equilibre france allemagne va être
rompu il va être rompu il savait trop
issia lisez avec le traité de nice quant
au sein de l'union européenne
le principe d'égalité scrupuleuse la
france et l'allemagne avaient le même
nombre de voix de représentants va être
modifié au prorata de la règle de la
population c'est à dire que l'allemagne
étant plus peuplé que la france doit
avoir plus de représentants que la
france hélas chirac ce bête se battra
comme un beau diable comme ils savaient
le faire
j'arrive presque lui seul savait le
faire et perdra y perdra ses les
allemands qui vont avoir gain de cause
et là on voit on commence à voir
équilibre france allemagne qui va
s'accentuer pourra y revenir bien
évidemment mais c'est voilà la france
des années 60 non vous avez raison
l'europe des années 60 c'était une
europe
idéal pour les pour les français elle
était à la taille de l'économie
française de l'époque et l'equilibre
français le match france-allemagne
marché plutôt bien marché plutôt bien
levé deux pays qui étaient à peu près il
en avait pas les mêmes forces et les
mêmes faiblesses mais disons que ça
s'équilibre est quelque part de les deux
s'équilibrent mais il reste quand on
revient sur là dessus en général on dit
oui mais depuis ces années soixante dix
depuis la crise du pétrole en gros tout
a changé tout est nouveau il ya une
accélération de la mondialisation et que
donc on ne peut plus penser comme on
pensait autrefois du temps où vous
voulez absolument respecter ses grands
équilibres quand il était menacé
et pour ce faire on avait recours au
protectionnisme on pense par exemple la
crise du pétrole c'est nouveau et vous
dites-vous n'ont pas tellement puisque
avant on souffre aujourd'hui de ne pas
avoir de pétrole non s'ouvrait hier de
ne pas avoir de charbon et le charbon
c'est l'équivalent du pétrole est
d'ailleurs la france va commencer à
connaître un développement industriel
aussi important à la fin des années 50
début des années 60 quand le pétrole se
substitue au charbon à l'époque le
pétrole est bon marché on est avant 73
avant les crises des pétroliers le
pétrole est bon marché et la france va
connaître un boom avec l'industrie
automobile l'industrie pétrochimique et
ses terrains qui vont petits vont se
développer
non la france a été et est dépendante à
l'époque plutôt de deux surtout avant 14
de l'est de l'angleterre
porter beaucoup de charbon de
l'angleterre et les anglais de dominer
le marché charbonnier internationale
avec la city avec la place financière
est aussi avec leurs flottes
commerciales qui était de loin la
première du monde mais qui transportait
le charbon et les français à acheter du
charbon acquis aux anglais et aux
allemands alors aux allemands ont acheté
moins mais c'était un charbon comment
dire de qualité c'était du coq et on
avait besoin de coqs pour faire tourner
nos aciéries et c'est donc on était à
l'époque dépendant plutôt de
l'angleterre et de l'allemagne pour le
charbon alors la france avait du minerai
de fer elle pouvait exporter des
minerais de fer la question c'est que le
minerai de fer coûter moins cher en
valeur relative que le charbon et donc
il y avait il ya eu une dépendance
énergétique de la france qui a duré des
années 1870 aux années 60 après 1905 à
fin des années 50 début des années 60 si
vous voulez à peu près ça colle avec eux
donc à l'époque on allait donc la crise
énergétique qui qui commença en 73
en fait elle n'est pas nouvelle de même
la la concurrence des pays ni aînés
émergents sassi et c'est là aussi qu'il
ya eu aussi des pays émergents avant
avec lesquels on sert pas les met en
concurrence elle ne sort qu'à l'époque
c'était les etats-unis ou faisait alors
fait alors dans les années dans les
années d'avant 14
c'est plutôt les pays agricole du
nouveau monde ont etats unis canada
argentine qui vont qui vont nous tailler
des croupières dans le domaine agricole
parce qu'ils sont évidemment ils sont
plus compétitifs incontestable et puis
de l'autre côté il y aura toute une
série de pays industriels qui vont
émerger après guerre et alors on est
surpris c'est l'inde l'un d'eux
concurrencera jusqu'à l'angleterre et et
elle fait partie de l'empiré britannique
mais ça on le dit plus aujourd'hui
mais les indiens concurrencer les
textiles de manchester dans les années
20 30
il y aura la chine il y aura le japon
alors pas la russie puisque la russie
s'est replié après les années 20 dans
son pré carré national c'est suffisant
même s'il est immense et donc c'est la
russie de staline donc elle est
complètement en dehors du marché mondial
ou quasiment
hors du marché mondial mais on voit
réapparaître une série de brix fédérer
avant la lettre l'inde la chine le japon
qui sont qui sont qui étaient des pics
très très actif et très émergents sur le
marché international et sur le plan
agricole
on verra apparaître dans les années 30
ce qu'on appelait l'europe danubienne
c'est à dire les pays de l'europe
centrale qui vont pendant la crise des
années 30 chercher à exporter leurs
produits agricoles chez nous et la
france sera obligé de relever ces
barrières douanières dans les années 30
pour se protéger de cette concurrence
qui étaient proches inquiété de des pays
comme la hongrie la roumanie la bulgarie
c'est quoi inquiéter qui étaient étaient
devenus des pays concurrents de sur le
plan agricole
donc contrairement à ce qu'on croit
quand on regarde l'histoire on
s'aperçoit que la france elle a nagé
toujours entre la comment dire des pays
concurrents avec des pays émergents avec
une dépendance énergétique assez forte
avec le fait qu' elle n'était pas une
économie dominante là la france n'a
jamais été une économie dominante elle a
cherché à rester j'emploie une
comparaison sportive mais à rester un
petit peu dans le sillage des grands ça
plutôt été ça alors on peut dire c'est
un manque d'ambition c'est sans fin je
veux pas rentrer dans le débat c'est
vrai ça nous amènerait très loin mais
dix ans je pense que l'ambition des
français c'était de rester au contact
avec les grandes puissances de l'époque
etats unis grande bretagne allemagne qui
étaient les grands pères le japon va
petit à petit dans les années 20
commencez à devenir un pays qui compte
aussi à l'époque on va commencer à
parler beaucoup du japon la france reste
au contact avec ces pays et reste au
contact elle est derrière mais elle est
pas l ai pas lâché d'une certaine façon
elle est derrière mais n'est pas n'est
pas complètement décroché alors qu'elle
n'a pas la puissance du cpu
incontestablement mais elle s'accroche
et ses positions on fait une pause on se
retrouve juste après on continue
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec l'économiste
yves perez qui publie les vertus du
protectionnisme aux éditions de
l'artilleur pour vous là la rupture se
fait en 1974 avec l'arrivée de valéry
giscard d'estaing à l'elysée c'est là
qu'on qu'on se dirige plus résolument
vers un système de libre échange
mondialiste et lorsque l'on observe
c'est que depuis lors la position de la
france s'est détériorée ce qu'elle avait
réussi à préserver tout au long du
siècle précédent quand elle elle
n'hésitait pas à se servir du
protectionnisme elle l'aurait perdu
d'après ce que vous dites
à partir de là tout aurait changé et eon
notre défaveur
oui tout à fait alors je suis pas le
premier à le dire il ya eu avant moi
un économiste infiniment plus alice
illustre que moi c'est maurice allais un
autre prix nobel de premiers prix nobel
d'économie qui l'avait très bien
démontré
il y avait montré que à partir
évidemment l'année soit 14 c'est pas
c'est pas l'année en tant que tel mais
c'est le début d'une rupture je dirais
un changement profond et on voit que la
france commence à perdre du terrain
alors après il ya d'autres phénomènes
qui vont accentuer ce retard l'allemagne
se réunifie donc l'allemagne retrouve
une centralité économique
je parle pas du politique évidemment
mais économique en europe est
essentielle fondamentale
la france se retrouve defacto dans une
position secondes par rapport par
rapport à l'allemagne
et on voit une france qui va se
spécialiser sur des créneaux et des
credo de plus en plus étroit d'une
certaine façon qui ne lui permettent pas
d'équilibrer sa balance commerciale
la france va avoir une balance
commerciale déficitaire elle l'est
toujours
on est en est avec grosso modo chaque
année avec un déficit de l'ordre de 50
milliards d'euros de déficit
quand l'allemagne est à peu près à 240
milliards d'euros les années normales en
2020 il y en a été une année un peu
particulière le même en 2020 l'écart est
resté quasi à peu près le même
l'allemagne à 240 milliards d'euros
d'excédent la france à 50 je vois
parfois 60 milliards d'euros de déficit
ou et l'écart il est à peu près de 300
milliards d'euros chaque année
france allemagne on peut dire que c'est
net c'est net et sans bavure alors quand
ça se reproduit sur 5 ans 10 ans 15 ans
20 ans il est évident que ça donne tout
autre dimension économique à l'allemagne
l'allemagne est une puissance économique
mondiale
la france n'est qu'une puissance
économique européenne voilà c'est ce
qu'on peut dire pour en résumant les
choses
bien sûr on pourrait il faudrait le
nuancer jeu après mais c'est quand même
l'essentiel et la france a cru qu'elle
allait pouvoir s'en tirer alors on s'est
lancé dans une politique de
restructuration mais qui n'a pas si tu
n'as pas été suffisant beaucoup de nos
fleurons sont tombés sous pavillon
étranger à la liste est longue
dans la plupart des industries qu'est ce
qui reste aujourd'hui comme point fort
de la france à l'export alors y reste
l'aérospatiale la défense va
l'aéronautique la défense
les industries de défense il reste
l'automobile mais avec un point
d'interrogation
saura-t-on gérer le pas la transition
énergétique le passage à l'électrique et
l'hybride aussi bien que nos voisins
allemands qui ont nos voisins allemands
par exemple qui ont déjà fortement
investi dans ce secteur point
d'interrogation le nucléaire civil là je
pars soit nucléaire civil où la france
était forte et là où elle a perdu du
terrain perdu du terrain
aujourd'hui on voit la russie la chine
qui commence à pointer du nez sur ce
secteur de façon forte alors que la
france qui était à l'exception des états
unis qui était le pays le plus avancé du
monde dans ce secteur
excepté les états unis on voit
aujourd'hui la france sur le nucléaire
civil qui marque le pas qui a des
difficultés parce que elle a moins
investi ces derniers temps sur ce
secteur et qu'elle n'a pas forcément
pris non plus
efforts technologiques l'effort de
recrutement de compétences alors qu'elle
avait les compétences des compétences
vraiment de très haut vol dans ce
secteur il ya eu un phénomène un petit
peu de voix la 2d cramponnage voilà ça
c'est je dirais il ya le luxe alors ça
le luxe est ancien s'est même autrefois
d'ailleurs l'industrie l'activité
catering dire la branche d'activité qui
a toujours été la plus libre échangiste
en france y compris durant le siècle
protectionnistes c'était l'industrie du
luxe
elle ne serait de luxe a toujours été la
plus libre échangiste qu'ils soient en
france elle a été forte elle était forte
elle est restée forte sous le
protectionnisme comme sous le libre
échange
c'est une performance caractéristiques
de la france mais soyons clairs on n'a
pas beaucoup de secteurs dits en dehors
de ce secteur là à quelque part s'il ya
passé un temps toutes les conjonctures
dans toutes les périodes les plus
difficiles luxe a toujours rebondi fait
partie de l'image de la france à
paraître plus long là dessus mais c'est
exceptionnel
on n'est plus dans l'exception que la
règle quand on fait la comparaison entre
le siècle protectionnistes en france et
ce qui est arrivé depuis depuis qu'on
s'est beaucoup plus ouvert à l'économie
libre échangiste on peut dire comme vous
l'avez dit en fait il n'y a pas tant de
différences que ça dans le sens où il y
avait déjà une dépendance à l'énergie on
dépend des de l'extérieur pour l'énergie
il y avait un certain nombre de deux
points communs avec aujourd'hui mais il
ya quand même une grosse différence à
mes yeux c'est consommer beaucoup moins
dans la france d'autrefois celle qu'on
voit défiler derrière moi toutes ces
photos en noir et blanc c'est pas un
pays consommateur comme nous sommes
devenus depuis est ce que est ce qu'on
pourrait être protectionniste sans que
notre consommation en souffrent alors
c'est vrai que la france de l'époque
était une france d'épargnants ce qui a
changé beaucoup si l'arrivée du web
first et de l'état providence après à
partir des années 50 60
en protégeant les français sur des
grands risques de la vie
on a à baisser mécaniquement le taux
d'épargné est donc au profit de la
consommation
la question aujourd'hui j'ai tendance à
dire il ya deux en fait
la première c'est que les français se
sont habitués à consommer effectivement
des produits importés et on importe des
produits les plus divers et les plus
variés alors là il ya une réflexion à
avoir par rapport à tout ce qu'on a pu
dire sur la relocalisation sur la
proximité sur la volonté de de produire
dans des périmètres raisonnable sur le
plan écologique
il ya une vraie réflexion à avoir d'une
certaine façon là d'une certaine façon
le je le dis dans mon bouquin mais le
mode de d'économie protéger de la france
de la fin du 19e et de la première
moitié du 20e siècle était beaucoup plus
écologique que l'actuel ça c'est une
vraie question
si on veut véritablement aller vers un
mode de vie une économie plus écologique
on fera pas l'économie de cette
réflexion à mon avis c'est un point
important
ça c'est ce qui me paraît important donc
c'est pour moi c'est moins le fait de
consommer que de quel type de
consommation et donc là si on couple
réflexion sur le retour à un certain
niveau de souveraineté économique des
réflexions sur ce qu'on appelle la
transition écologique
on doit se reposer la question d'un
certain niveau de protection d'un
certain niveau d'autonomie
alors on sait qu'aujourd'hui il ya des
discussions y compris au sein de l'union
européenne sur la taxe carbone sur le
fait de vouloir taxer certaines
importations
alors soit pour des raisons sociales à
cause du travail des enfants des femmes
et des enfants des travail de nuit des
femmes et des enfants
ou au contraire pour des raisons
écologiques
ça c'est sur le tapis actuellement on
verra la suite qu'il va être donné à
travers les discussions avec l'union
européenne et les débats dans l'union
européenne mais le débat est sur le
tapis en quelque sorte
alors ça c'est une vraie question c'est
quel type de consommation
pour si on veut être cohérent avec un
développement plus équilibré sur le plan
sur le plan écologique et énergétique
différence c'est là où il y aurait une
inspiration pour une relecture à faire
un peu du passé par rapport à ça il perd
l on va pas se mentir le l'économie
ouverte dans laquelle nous vivons
aujourd'hui c'est le paradis du
consommateur c'est à dire que c'est
certainement le paradis des actionnaires
mais c'est aussi le paradis du
consommateur c'est les prix les moins
chers toujours dans une économie plus
protectionniste c'est évident que les
prix montrait que ce serait plus le
paradis du consommateur qu'on trouverait
plus en abondance ce que l'on trouve
aujourd'hui
indépendamment de tout ceci écologique
ce ne serait plus alors le l'hypermarché
dans lequel nous vivons depuis dans puis
quasiment maintenant un demi siècle
alors la question c'est est ce que
finalement alors je vais essayer de
rebondir par rapport aux 2 questions
elle est fondamentale et la question
c'est est ce que finalement c'est hyper
marché dans lequel nous vivons est il
durable
d'une certaine façon moi c'est la
question je poserai il me semble que ça
ne l'est pas durable et qu' il va
falloir abandonner qu'on revienne à des
modes de consommation plus lié à la
proximité plus lié à la notion dans
l'écologie que la notion de durabilité
j'allais dire dans le temps et ça je
crois que c'est lui ça me paraît être un
débat de fond
c'est vrai vous avez raison ce que vous
dites est juste la question étant que on
en arrive à ce paradoxe on l'a vu aux
états unis sont mamans d'élection de
trump pourquoi trump a été élu parce que
les américains importants importés en
asie du sud-est et en chine
aux etats unis les uns portent à bon
marché résultat on a ruiné des pans
entiers de l'économie américaine est
d'ailleurs soit dit en passant il n'est
pas sûr que le plan byden de relance by
donne ne change grand chose au phénomène
l'église parce qu'on s'est trop tôt mais
pour ce qu'on sait pour l'instant les
américains continue à importer
massivement des biens de consommation
produits outre autre amérique
en asie pour ne pas la nommer et en
chine alors ça c'est la question c'est
quand on arrive à un point où quand le
roi le consommateur roi menacent
l'emploi menace l'activité dans certains
secteurs importants
on l'a vu pendant la santé quand on
était suspendue à l'arrivée des masques
et des appareils respiratoires en
provenance de chine
c'était quand même une situation un peu
désagréable pour beaucoup de monde donc
il ya un moment donné ou un pays doit se
poser la question qu'est ce qui est
essentiel qu'est ce qu'il doit garder d'
essentiel en termes de production
s'il envisage son développement il faut
qu'il envisage sur la durée à l'écologie
comme skistar envisager les choses sur
la durée si on veut être cohérent
sinon mon avis on pas dans le vide un
quelque part je crois que tous ces
éléments là sont à prendre en compte
pour repenser le modèle des blancs peut
pas à la fois dire on va protéger
l'économie française de l'économie
européenne
si on ne répond pas aux autres questions
qui vont forcément se poser derrière et
sinon vous avez raison les libéraux ont
beau jeu de dire enfin libre échangiste
ont beau jeu de dire que effectivement
consommateur est roi et qu'on va payer
plus cher c'est vrai qu'on peut payer
plus cher certaines choses mais de
l'autre côté
parfois ces shows sont essentielles
cantine c'est une question qui touche à
la santé qui touche à la sécurité qui
touche
oui il vaut mieux que ce soit que pas
parce qu'à force d'être dépendant des
foi de certains pays on peut se mettre
dans des mains je dirais parfois
indélicates
je dirais pas plus loin mais on peut
donner des verges pour se faire battre
d'une certaine façon c'est le risque si
c'est vrai que les dirigeants d'autres
hôtes de la france protectionnistes
étaient très sensibles à ça il est très
sensible à vous fait de ne pas dépendre
excessivement d'un pays
alors l'angleterre en dépendent et
d'angleterre pour le charbon bon
l'angleterre était qu un manadier avec
l'allemagne s'étaient déjà plus
compliqué voilà mais on ne faisait
attention à ça aujourd'hui c'est vrai
qu'on a complètement gommé cet aspect là
et on le redécouvre on découvre que la
santé la sécurité c'est des biens
collectifs sont des biens
je dirais pas qu'ils n'ont pas de prix
ils ont ils ont des prix et des prix qui
peut être parfois prêts à payer si on ne
veut pas demain pleurer en disant on n'a
pas si on n'a pas ça ce qui nous est
arrivé là avec les conséquences qu'on a
pu mesurer pendant des mois et des mois
enfin pendant plus d'un an il se trouve
que les instruments informatiques les
outils informatiques que l'on a beaucoup
utilisé depuis le début de la pandémie
ce sont des outils américain le prix à
payer c'est que on nous surveille on
accumule des données que nous mêmes ne
sommes pas capables de collecter de
notre côté mais c'est trop tard
maintenant on n'arrivera pas à revenir
dans le jeu on est sorti du jeu
informatique depuis longtemps maintenant
on va pas se mettre demain se remettra à
fabriquer des ordinateurs des téléphones
même des télévisions on n'est plus
capable de les fabriquer non plus et
alors de fabriquer un google france s
est absolument hors de question
les chinois l'ont fait parce qu'ils s'y
sont mis tout de suite et que c'est
l'état qui a obligé mais en europe ça
s'est pas passé des familles sont là ni
l'europe ni la france n'ont assisté pour
qu'on ait aidé des outils à nous qui
assure notre indépendance et on va pas
rêver c'est pas maintenant qu'on va
commencer à les fabriquer alors deux
choses
la preuve le problème c'est qu'on a
laissé filer beaucoup beaucoup de choses
des choses qu'on n'aurait jamais dû
laisser filer
on les a laissé filer en dix ans
maintenant c'est plus nécessaire de le
faire ici les sons achetant à l'étranger
etc et à se première première chose
deuxième chose c'est que pourra pas vous
avez raison de dire qu'on pourra pas
tout reconquérir qu'on pourra pas tout
mais il ya quand même un certain nombre
de domaines un certain nombre d'éléments
ou si on ne le fait pas un effort si cet
effort est tardif il sera moins
spectaculaire que celui qu'on fait
chinois et chinois s'y sont pris
beaucoup plus tôt c'est vrai mais si on
fait pas là le risque c'est
effectivement l'accroissement des
dépendance vis-à-vis des grandes
puissances qui pointe à l'horizon enfin
qui sont déjà des grandes puissances ou
celle qui pointe à l'horizon
alors c'est pas un sort enviable c'est
pas un sort enviable l'europe les quand
même été une puisse enfin pour le centre
alité pendant pendant des siècles qui
donne un coup va s'effacer
c'est ça la question c'est habité
aujourd'hui à dire au fond il faut ici
fonds investis en investi dans la durée
par exemple quand le général de gaulle
et pompidou créé les centrales
nucléaires ils pensent à 40 ans
la question aujourd'hui c'est que si tu
es moi enfin m'excuse de vous dire ça je
me redresse pas vous en tant que tel
mais est-ce qu'on peut citer aujourd'hui
un homme politique quel qu'il soit de
droite de gauche du centre des ailes qui
pensent à 40 ans ou 50 en a pas beaucoup
les chinois pensent à 40 50 ans quand
les chinois disent en 2049 on veut être
la première puissance mondiale au niveau
économique technologique
il pense à 50 ans nous pas nous quand on
pense déjà à cinq ans et c'est qu'on est
déjà un visionnaire au delà de cinq ans
les gens disaient ont fumé la moquette
quoi quelque part pour me parler comme
les jésuites justement vous abordez dans
votre livre
il espérait une rupture s'est opérée
sous avec la vème république au fond qui
qui qui accompagne un commencement
d'ouverture alors progressif vers les
verts vers l'économie mondiale mais par
rapport le sous la 3ème et la 4ème
république le système politique était
bien plus décentralisée il reposait sur
un beau coup plus large consensus
national
l'élection du président de la république
pour prendre juste cet exemple se
faisait à travers les grands électeurs
ça n'était pas la démocratie
ce n'était pas le suffrage universel
direct comme la lala fait voter le
général de gaulle donc les maires des
petites communes rurales avait beaucoup
plus de pouvoir aujourd'hui que dans non
les électeurs
deux des petites communes rurales donc
on voit bien que ce changement que vous
analysez dans votre livre
il n'est pas seulement économique il est
également politique au front et la
répartition des gains a changé elle
aussi oui tout à fait incontestablement
la 3ème et 4ème but que c'était des
systèmes très décentralisé où les
électeurs avaient dû pouvoir en les
électeurs pouvaient influencer les
choses c'est alors évidemment ça pue
donné lieu aussi à des excès qu'on
connaît bien
critiques ont été adressées à ces
systèmes mais en même temps où il y
avait il y avait une proximité des
électeurs au système politique
en tout cas qui était totale mais elle
était beaucoup plus proche
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on
est dans un système qui est beaucoup
plus verticalisées on voit que tout se
joue sur l'élection présidentielle
d'ailleurs on ne pense qu'à ça d'une
certaine façon on est obsédé par cette
élection présidentielle ça a pris tout
le champ et effectivement les électeurs
ont le sentiment souvent d'être
dépossédés doudous des fois des
réactions y compris des réactions
parfois violentes d'une partie des
citoyens ont des français face à ce
qu'ils considèrent comme des possessions
bah c'est pas faux faut
incontestablement le protectionnisme est
allée de pair alors est-ce que c'est pas
forcément une règle mais c'est vrai
qu'en france il est allé de pair avec un
système parlementaire qui était très
très décentralisé où les intérêts locaux
était très représentée
effectivement effectivement tous les
hommes politiques devaient aller voir
les agriculteurs et les paysans ses
terres à discuter avec eux taper le
carton
aujourd'hui bon aujourd'hui gérée elle
salon de l'agriculture il ya ma faim
voilà c'était pas la même chose ya pa il
n'y a pas la même et pas la même
proximité
venir dire ça c'est vrai c'est un
changement profond qu'il y ait à la
naissance de la vème république à la au
président de la république est bien sûr
à l'arme nucléaire par définition est
l'armé nucléaire ne peut pas être se
balader entre 46 main et entame de
répartition des gains
comment savez comment ça se perd paraît
pas les léguer à eux qui qui profitait
au fond du décodeur d'assystem plus
protectionniste et qui a profité d'un
système plus ouvert
alors qu'ils profitaient d'un système
protectionniste il y avait
incontestablement les agriculteurs qui
étaient nombreux à l'époque même si le
nombre a décru mais le la transition de
l'agriculture de match aller dire vers
une agriculture plus plus plus
productiviste a été relativement lente
en france a été plus lente en france que
dans les autres pays occidentaux parce
que justement le protectionnisme fait
que voilà on y est a été très
progressivement
deuxièmement il y avait je dirais les
épargnants les épargnants étaient assez
protégé la plupart des régimes de la
troisième voire de la 4è unique
d'antoine pinay et là encore pas qu'à
droite à gauche aussi chacun pouponner
cesser ces épargnants c'est pas toujours
les mains mais il y avait également les
industriels qui dépend des fois qu'ils
pouvaient bénéficier de marchés protégés
alors ceux qui en ont souffert
on peut dire que c'était certaines
industries comment dire
traditionnellement exportatrices alors
je parlais du luxe il y en avait
d'autres enfin c'était celle qui vient
en premier et qui elles ont plutôt
souffert du système maison
probablement il aurait pu gagner plus
d'argent et stablement c'est toi alors
dans la lho économie ouverte qu'est ce
qu'ils gagnent ce qu'ils gagnent
ce sont un certain nombre de grandes
entreprises qui se sont adaptés au jeu
de la mondialisation et leurs
actionnaires bien évidemment qui sont
parmi les vainqueurs
et puis bien sûr une population de
cadres cadres moyens et supérieurs qui
peuvent être liés à ces entreprises
ça donne les clivages que je
le site un peu de mon livre le premier
en parler bien évidemment je me suis
appuyé sur des travaux déjà existants
grosso modo il ya trois france c'est ce
qu'a dit très très bien jérôme fourquet
je crois dans son livre sur l'archipel
français il ya la france des métropoles
grosso modo c'est à peu près 25% des
français qui vivent dans les métropoles
ou autour des métropoles qui sont dans
la mondialisation qui sont bénéficiaires
de la mondialisation qui sont pour une
europe de plus en plus intégrée de plus
en plus ouverte
il y a environ 40% à 45% des français
s'alarme un peu plus 50% des français
qui vivent dans ce qu'on appelle la
france périphérique donc là c'est les
ouvriers des employés des pme sous
traitantes c'est des gens qui
travaillent dans la distribution dans le
petit commerce et ses terres à
l'agriculture et qui eux sont plutôt du
côté des perdants même si c'est pas
toujours pour tous mais du côté des
perdants alors c'est corrigé par les
aides de l'état par la redistribution
c'est la politique de redistribution de
l'état qui évite j'allais dire des cas
sur beaucoup plus visible est beaucoup
plus importante qu'elle ne le sont et
puis la dernière france et la france des
banlieues alors qu' elle est un petit
peu gelé dire on sait pas trop quand
elle se positionne elle est un peu elle
a un pied dans la mondialisation defacto
puisqu'elle vient de l'étranger
enfin familialement il pas forcément
tout de suite général il vient de
l'extérieur qu'elle a beaucoup de
références notamment dans le monde anglo
saxon je pense aux états unis je pense
aux noirs américains etc qui servent
souvent de références culturelles
sportives musicales etc
c'est très profond et puis il ya une
partie qui est plutôt d'une certaine
façon plutôt proches au fond de la
france périphérique un banquet voilà il
ya cette troisième france qui est la
france des banlieues qui représente 15
15 20 % de la population pour aimer ton
15% sur le français voilà je donne les
grandes masses 1 je dis pas c'est pas la
virgule près mais c'est les trois
grandes masses
grosso modo la tripartition auquel on
assiste actuellement et qu'on voit se
traduire sur le plan électoral ensuite
après dans les clivages électoraux entre
ceux qui votent et qui ne votent pas et
ceux qui votent pour certains candidats
et pas d'autres et vice et versa donc on
a en a 7
cette disposition je dirais chose merci
yves perez d'avoir été mon invité
pendant toute cette heure les vertus du
protectionnisme ça vient de paraître aux
éditions de l'artilleur on peut dévoiler
la fin vous dites qu'il ya quand même
assez peu de chances pour que dans le
cadre européen actuel on ne revienne au
protectionnisme ça suppose des
aménagements des aménagements qui sont
pas totalement impossible mais qui
demanderont des réaménagements
importante du mode de fonctionnement
actuel de l'union européenne oui oui
merci beaucoup c'est paru aux éditions
de l'artilleur merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]